[Music]
they're avid swimmers and avid swingers
and all this swimming and swinging sure
works up what else
a gigantic appetite no one like there's
what you know and what you don't know
and what you don't know you don't know
the Mukesh no there's food here what
they don't know is that the guy who set
up this operation is making bootleg
liquor by fermenting fruit and what they
don't know they don't know is what
happens when a relatively tiny macaque
body encounters the kind of liquor that
can lay out a 200-pound human if
ignorance is bliss these macaques have
achieved euphoria
[Music]
nothing left to do but try to sleep at
all
[Music]